翻訳: Motoko Mukaiyama
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私の社会人としての第一歩は
鋼鉄の製造をする会社から始まりました
現在はアニメーションを
製造する会社を経営しています
そうです
アニメーションの「製造」です
今 後ろでお見せしているような作品です
「鋼鉄」の後に「製造」と言っても
誰も不思議とは思いませんよね
ではアニメーションを「製造する」は？
ちょっと変に聞こえますか
アニメーションを作っているのは
アーティストだと思ってますよね
アニメーターとかクリエーターとか
でも「製造」とは
関係がなさそうな人たちですよね
実際 日本では
クリエイティブ産業に従事する者に対する
共通の概念のようなものがあります
固定概念とも言えるようなものです
どんな固定概念か いくつか挙げてみましょう
例えば みんなエキセントリック
奇想天外で
何をしでかすか全くわからない
あるいは破天荒で常軌を逸している
このタイプの人間は生活のほとんどを
創造活動に費やしてしまう
睡眠まで犠牲にして
時間をかければかけるほど
プロジェクトの出来は良くなる
太陽なんてくそくらえ
創造力ってのは
真夜中から早朝に発揮されるものなんだ！
チームワーク？ スケジュール？ 予算？
そんなの知ったことじゃない
ましてや締め切りなんて
芸術ってのは
時間をかけて成熟させるものなんだ
個人的で孤独なプロセスなんだ
ほっといてくれ
終わったら呼ぶ！
要するに
私たちは世間から隔絶した
人間の集まりだと思われているんです
クリエイティブという小さい泡に閉じこもり
社会から疎外されていると
クリエイティブ職と管理職は
どうにも良い関係を築けない
でも今日はその認識を変えたいのです
アニメーションの制作というのは
実はとても細かくて
統制のとれたプロセスだということ
そして関わっている人たちも
ただ芸術的な才能があるだけではなく
同じように統制がとれているのだということ
創造力も管理をすることが可能なのです
鋼鉄の製造会社に入社してすぐに
北九州の製鉄所でインターンをしました
まずはとにかく
その施設の大きさに驚きました
でもその作業は対照的に
とても緻密だったのです
そして管理は高度な技術で行われていました
でも私の心を最も動かしたのは
そこで働いていた人たちでした
彼らが日々仕事に傾けていた情熱に
感動したのです
仕事のことを話すときの彼らの目が —
大きく開き輝いていたのを覚えています
彼らの先人たちの話も聞きました
より良い鋼鉄を生み出すために何をしたか
コンピューターやセンサーなどを使い
高炉の中で燃え盛る炎や —
その他の自然現象をどう制御したのか
昔は想像すらできなかったことです
これほど繊細なオペレーションは
何十年もの経験を積んだ熟練工の目や感覚や
そして直感に頼って行われてきたのですから
そして熟練工たちはこう思っていました
コンピューターに
この人間の業を真似ることはできないだろうと
でも彼らはそれをやってのけたのです
そして その結果として
さらに品質の良い
安定した大量の鋼鉄を
生産できるようになったのです
このような話に私は深い感銘を受けました
やがて時間が経ち
意図せずデジタルアニメーションの世界に
飛び込んだとき
うれしい驚きがありました
アニメーション制作の工程が
鋼鉄の製造工程と似ていたのです
鋼鉄の製造と同様に
制作ラインを作り人員を配置します
特定の技能を持ち責務を負った人々が
一致団結して仕事をします
材料が流れていくのと同様に
データが流れていきます
そして鋼鉄製品や自動車の代わりに
アニメーションが製造されるのです
簡単に制作工程の詳細をご紹介しましょう
どんなアニメーションでも
まずはストーリーから始まります
ピクサーのジョン・ラセターが
繰り返し言うように
「ストーリーこそが王」なのです
ストーリーは偉大な監督が
生み出すこともあるし
私たちが自社で制作した
『シドニアの騎士』のように
漫画が原案になる場合もあります
『シドニアの騎士』はすばらしいアーティスト
弐瓶勉の作品です
そしてストーリーから脚本が作られます
ストーリーに出てくるものは
すべてデザインしなければなりません
そして視覚的連続性を確保するために
絵コンテが作られます
これらすべてのものが設計図になるのです
いわゆるアニメーション「製造」のための
そして制作が開始され
デザインを基にCGモデルが作られます
モデリングという作業は
コンピューター内で行う彫刻のようなものです
画面に登場するものすべてを
モデリングしなければなりません
ヒーローもロボットもヒロインも
悪役も宇宙船も環境も
そしておにぎりも
もちろん納豆だって！ ヒーローも
食べなくちゃ生きられないですから
腹が減っては戦ができぬ
でしょう？
そして骨やリグがモデルに組み込まれ
アニメーターがモデルを自由に —
コントロールできるようになります
アニメーターはコントロールを使い
モノでしかなかったものに命を吹き込むのです
関節一つ一つに動きをつけます
腕のいいプロのアニメーターが
丸一日作業をしても
３秒から５秒ほどの
動きしかつけられません
ということは人が大勢必要ということです
一話22分を作り上げるために
協力して取り組む必要があるのです
照明担当が場面の雰囲気を決めます
屋内もあれば屋外もあります
夏や秋の場合もあるし
昼間だったり夜間だったりもします
そして3700ノードのCPUを持つ
メッシュネットワークで
900万を越えるファイルをコンパイルし
すべての要素を計算するのです
それぞれのプロジェクトが
57TBのデータを使用します
『シドニアの騎士』の制作は
次のように行われました
世界12カ国から集まった
178人ものスタッフが
人生の203,680時間分を費やして
43,000のタスクをこなし
8,400ショットを完成させ
最終的に528分もの
アニメーションを作り上げました
フー！ 一息で言い切るのも大変な量です
これを実際にやることを考えてみてください！
ありがたいことに制作にかかわるのは
アーティストだけではありません
プロダクションマネージャーや
コーディネーターが
大量の情報やそのやりとりを
時間単位で管理します
仕事の環境はデジタルですが
お互いの顔を見ながらの会話もします
海外との打ち合わせは
テレビ会議で行います
顔を合わせることも同じくらい大切ですからね
プロダクションの成功には 今も昔も
良いコミュニケーションが欠かせません
もうお分かりですよね
アニメーションを作り上げるのに必要なのは
芸術性だけではないのです
芸術性と構造化されたプロセス
そして良い管理が組み合わさってはじめて
創造性が発揮されるのです
私はこんなことを望んでいます
製造業には管理と運用に関して
膨大な知識と専門性の蓄積があります
我々の元には才能豊かなアーティストがいます
世界で最も大量かつ多様なアニメーション
コンテンツを制作するともいえる人的資産です
この２つをうまく組み合わせるのです
そうしたら我々は
この産業で最高峰に立てるはずです
しかも世界レベルで
この目的のために
私たちは繰り返し
「カイゼン」を実行してきました
より効率を高め
技術的に進歩するためです
ただ正直に言うと
当初は反発もありました
抵抗するアーティストもいたのです
こんな意見がありました
効率性を重視すると
逆に創造性が失われてしまう
製造業での「カイゼン」の実行は
良い手段かもしれないが
創造活動に適用はできない
私はこのような意見は押し返してきました
高炉の中で燃え盛る炎の話を引用して
諭しました
「製鉄所の人たちは
火や他の自然現象の制御方法を考案したんだ
コンピューターを使い
より良い鉄を作った
絶え間ないカイゼンによって実現した
君たちは ―
自分の心や行動が 火や自然現象よりも
もっと不安定で予測不可能と言うのか？」
しばらく経つと
かなりの結果が目に見え始めました
プロジェクトによっては効率性が
25%以上も改善されました
ただもっと重要なのは
アーティストたちが気付き始めたことです
改善されたワークフローのおかげで
単調で不必要な作業を
しなくてよくなったことに
節約できた時間を使って
本当にクリエイティブな作業ができ
品質が上がったことに
創造性が失われるどころか
向上させることができたのです
我々が行った「カイゼン」は
最終的にエミー賞の複数受賞として
評価が得られました
『トランスフォーマー プライム』が
受賞したのです
エミー賞の受賞は映画で
アカデミー賞を受賞するのと同じ栄誉です
ここまで
他産業から借りてきたものについて
お話してきました
でも自産業から学んだ
管理の原則がひとつあります
それは私が何よりも大切にしているものです
何だか分かりますか？
それは「モチベーションの管理」です
あなたはなぜ毎朝起きて
仕事に行けるのか？
もちろん根本的な理由もあるでしょう
自分や家族を養うためというのも
そのひとつです
でも行かねばならないから仕事に行くのか
それとも行きたいから行くのか
私たちの仕事は
人々の感情を呼び起こすものを作ることです
笑い 泣き あざけり 怒り 時には叫ぶ
視聴者の感情を呼び起こすためには
作る側も感情を込める必要があるのです
疑問をさしはさむ余地はありません
そうしなければうまくいかないのです
ではどのように感情を込めればいいのか
そう難しいことではないけれど
簡単でもありません
緊張感を持つことです
自分の認識を頑固なまでに守ることです
いちばんは自分たちが信じる
プロジェクトに携わることです
自分たちが愛し
誇りを持って見せられる作品に
視聴者からの反応が究極のご褒美です
制作現場には前向きなエネルギーが満ちていて
楽しくて心地よくあるべきです
スタッフには精神的にも身体的にも
健康でいてもらう必要があります
私たちは仕事と同じくらいのエネルギーを
パーティにも使います
陽気で協力的で社交的な雰囲気を作るのに
それが役に立つと思うからです
そして もちろん
スタッフが家族や大切な人たちと過ごす時間を
十分に持てるようにする必要もあります
人生を切り開き
楽しむ余裕もなければなりません
でもこれは私たちの産業だけに
言えることなのでしょうか
私はそうは思いません
すべてのビジネスが
楽しめるはずだし そうあるべきです
すべてのビジネスにおいて
創造力は発揮されるべきです
それはすべてのビジネスが革新や
効率性を得るため努力をするのと同じことです
私たちが他産業から学んできたように
他産業に従事する人も
私たちを見てほしいのです
エキセントリックで
おかしなやつらとしてではなく
刺激を与えることができる者として
商品やサービスの向上のために
人々はただソフトウェアや
ハードウェアを買うのではなく
自分の感情を巧い具合に
高揚させてくれる製品を買うのです
私たちが管理や運営について
他産業から学んだように
私たちからも学んでほしいのです
感情という重要な要素を
商品やサービスに加える方法を
本当の協力からしか
本当に新しい商品やサービスを
生み出すことはできません
一緒にやりましょう！
私たちはそんなにオカシクないですよ
楽しんでいるだけなのです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）